Namo tassa bhagavato harahato sambha sambhudassa Namo tassa bhagavato harahato sambha sambhudassa
Namo tassa bhagavato harahato samma sambodassam Homage to the Buddha, the blessed, noble and fully self-enlightened one.
So, I'm continuing these little evening talks using Bhikkhu Bodhi's book, In the Buddha's Words, an anthology.
And I thought to begin at the beginning, instead of going all over the place.
And it starts off with what he calls a human condition.
And, you know, when the Buddha came to his realization, he saw a sort of end to this suffering business.
So if you can imagine a doctor, the sort of awkwardness of having to tell somebody they have a terminal illness and that there's no chance of it being healed.
So, I mean, they might say, well, you might last nine months, one year, two years, but the news is really bad, you see.
And it must be difficult, even if they've done it many times, to actually have to say that to somebody, knowing the shock and the horror that it causes in people.
And it must be similar if somebody has a chronic illness, something like rheumatoid arthritis or something, or something like that.
And they have to say to them, you know, we can't do anything about it, we can give you drugs and all that, but you're stuck with it.
So again, it's like there's a despairing note about it and no help.
Very different, of course, if the illness is something they can cure, then, you know, they're very happy to tell you that you'll be suffering miserably and terribly for a month.
But at the end, you'll be all right.
So when it comes to the harsh conditions of our life, the Buddha can be right in our face with it, you see, because he's got an answer.
He says, well, there is an end to this suffering.
So he can be fairly, you know, straight on the nose business.
And these passages just tell you how he doesn't pull his punches, you see.
He's talking here to King Pasenadi.
So there were two areas where he wandered.
He never really went over towards Bengal, towards Calcutta.
He stayed within that area, Varanasi, Benares, present-day Benares, all the way up to where his people lived, the Sakyas.
And he seems to have moved right over towards modern Delhi.
So he wandered, you know, he wandered for quite a while.
It was all over the place, really.
He just kept walking.
And there were two kings.
One was Pasenadi, who was the ruler of the northern part of that area, the Gangetic plain.
And there was Bimbisara in the south, who ruled the kingdom of Magadha.
So Pasenadi, he must have known, even as a child, because his...
his people, the Sakyas, would have been under that kingship.
You often hear the tales of the Buddha being the prince of a great king and all that.
But actually, it was a small tribe, the Sakyas, who lived on the borders of what is present-day Nepal.
And his father was the head man.
He was the chief and elective.
It would have been a more democratic thing.
Democratic only within that...
within that caste, the Kshatriyas, the warrior caste, the rulers.
And they came under the king of Kosala.
The king of Kosala was their lord, you might say.
Very feudal, you know.
There's no record as to whether they paid duty or anything like that.
But anyway, he obviously knows him.
And King Pasenadi became a great supporter of his.
So he's at the capital, Savatthi.
And King Pasenadi of Kosala said to the Blessed One, Venerable Sir, is anyone who is born free from aging and death?
He's obviously on his mind.
Great King, no one who is born is free from aging and death.
Even those affluent katiyas, so that's the ruling caste, rich with great wealth and property, with abundant gold and silver, abundant treasures and commodities, abundant wealth and grain,
because they've been born, are not free from aging and death.
Even those affluent Brahmins and those affluent householders with abundant wealth and grain, because they've been born, they're not free from aging and death.
Even those monks who are Arahats, fully liberated, whose taints are destroyed, who've lived the holy life, done what has to be done, laid down the burdens,
reached their own goal utterly destroyed the fetters of existence and are completely liberated through final knowledge even for them this body is subject to breaking up subject to being laid down see?
so there's no even somebody who's fully liberated has to go through the horror now we know that for instance Moggallana who was the who was one of his two main disciples and he was known for his powers
was seemingly murdered by bandits his other great disciple Sariputta seems to have died at home for peace Monday it would have been I think a sad thing for him that both of them died before he went when I was in Burma I saw a beautiful statue with the Buddha sitting and he had his hand pointing towards his heart like that you see so I'd never seen this mudra this
What's the word for mudra?
The position, you know, like you get them, well, like this one here, that's the samadhi posture.
And they said to me it was a sadness he felt when he heard that the two teachers who had brought him so far were dead and he had wanted to pass on his message to them.
So this tells us that, you know, sadness isn't beyond the Buddha.
He's sad, you see.
But he's not overwhelmed by it.
He's not grieving for it.
And there's a little phrase, there's a little verse that he creates.
The beautiful chariots of kings wear out.
This body too undergoes decay.
But the dharma of the good does not decay.
So the good proclaim along with the good.
A little verse just to remind us that.
The Dharma is beyond time.
It's Akalika.
One of the qualities of the Dharma that it exists as a law no matter what time or space you happen to be in.
So then he goes on and this is quite a long little passage but we'll sort of get through it.
So Asavati in the middle of the day King Pasenadi of Kosala approached the Blessed One paid homage to him and sat down to one side and the Blessed One then asked him
now where have you come from great king in the middle of the day just now venerable sir I've been engaged in those affairs of kingship typical for kings who are intoxicated with the intoxication of sovereignty who are obsessed by greed for sensual pleasures and who've attained stable control of their country and who rule having conquered a great sphere of territory on earth it's funny intoxicated with the intoxication
of sovereignty what do you think great king suppose a man would come to you from the east one who is trustworthy and reliable and would tell you for sure great king you should know this I'm coming from the east and there I saw a great mountain high as the clouds coming this way crushing all living beings do whatever you think should be done great king then a second man would come to you from the west and a third from the north and a fourth from the south
one who is trustworthy and reliable and would tell you, for sure, great king, you should know this.
I'm coming from the south, and then I saw a great mountain high as the clouds coming this way, crushing all living beings.
Do whatever you think should be done, great king.
If, great king, such a great peril should arise, such a terrible destruction of human life, the human state being so difficult to obtain, what should be done?
Oh, if, venerable sir, such a great peril should arise, such a terrible destruction of human life,
the human state being so difficult to obtain, what else should be done but to live by the Dharma, to live righteously and to do wholesome and meritorious deeds.
I inform you, great king, I announce to you, great king, aging and death are rolling in on you.
When aging and death are rolling in on you, great king, what should be done?
As aging and death are rolling in on me, venerable sir, what else should be done but to live by the Dharma, to live righteously and to do
wholesome and meritorious deeds.
Venerable sir, kings intoxicated with the intoxication of sovereignty, obsessed by greed for sensual pleasures, who've attained stable control of their country and rule over a great sphere of territory, conquer by means of elephant battles, cavalry battles, chariot battles and infantry battles.
But there is no hope of victory by such battles
no chance of success when aging and death are rolling in.
In this royal court, venerable sir, there are counselors who, when the enemies arrive, are capable of dividing them by subterfuge.
There is no hope of victory by subterfuge, no chance of success when aging and death are rolling in.
In this royal court, venerable sir, there exists abundant bullion and gold stored in vaults and lofts.
And with such wealth we are capable of mollifying the enemies when they come.
But there is no hope of victory by wealth, no chance of success when aging and death are rolling in.
As aging and death are rolling in on me, Venerable Sir, what else should I do but to live by Dharma, live righteously and do wholesome and meritorious deeds?
So it is, great king, so it is, great king, as aging and death are rolling in on you, what else should you do but live by Dharma, live righteously and do wholesome and meritorious deeds?
This is what the Blessed One said.
We can only hope that his words have some effect upon us and that we will live righteously and according to the Dharma.
May you be fully liberated from all suffering sooner rather than later.